[Music]  for generations this peaceful island has  been home to our family but beyond our  ease a great danger is coming  legend tells of a hero who will journey  to find the demigod Maui and together  they will save us all  when when when away  [Music]  semi-god of the wind and chi i heroic  men what it's actually Maui shapeshifter  demigod of the wind and sea hero of men  I interrupt it from the top hero of men  go impact going on a mission with some  little girls  he's my canoe and you will journey to  different did not see that coming the  ocean is a friend of mine first we got  to go through a whole ocean of bad Kaka  hora [ __ ] Oh what  they're kind of cute  the pocket  got your back it's Maori time  Oh  oh really  blow dart and my butt cheek we're going  to the realm of monsters don't worry  it's a lot farther down than it looks  [Music]  my  what